IF STEVE SPURRIER COLLEGE
WHO CAME TO THE NFL AND THEN
WE'RE NOT VERY GOOD BEFORE WE
GET TO THAT THOUGH. ONE OF MY
FAVORITE STEVE SPURRIER
QUOTES WHEN HE WAS NEW TO THE
TIME WAS THE COACH AT THE E
SAINTS. THEY WERE GETTING
READY TO PLAY AND SPURRIER
HASLETT COMES IN AT 4:30 IN
THE MORNING. THAT'S NOT DOING
HIM MUCH GOOD IT HAS
REMEMBER PASTOR WANTED TO
HAS I WANTED TO BE A MOM. SO I
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
THEY FINALLY PLAYED BUT
CHANCES ARE THE THE SAINTS
HANDLED THE WASHINGTON
FOOTBALL TEAM AT THE TIME.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST CHOICE TO
YOU SHIREEN GREAT COLLEGE
COACH THAT FLAMED OUT AT THE
NFL LEVEL.
WELL, YOU GOT TO STOP START
WITH BOBBY PETRINO, RIGHT?
THAT WAS A COLOSSAL FAILURE IN
2017 EVEN MAKE IT THROUGH A
WHOLE SEASON YOU TALK ABOUT
MICHAEL VICK GOT ARRESTED IN
THE DOGFIGHTING RING THAT
STARTED 3 AND 10 AND THEN HE
SAID SEE I'M OUT OF HERE. I'M
HEADED BACK TO ARKANSAS. AND
IF YOU REMEMBER MIKE AND I
HAD FORGOTTEN ABOUT THIS TILL
I STARTED IN MY RESEARCH
INFORMED THE PLAYERS HE PUT
THAT LAMINATED FOR SENATE
STATEMENT IN EACH ONE OF
THOSE LOCKERS AND
THAT'S HOW HE TOLD FALCONS
PLAYERS THAT HE WAS LEAVING
AND WORK DONE WHO NEVER SAID
A BAD WORD ABOUT ANYONE. YEAH.
HE WANTED TO BEAT UP BOBBY
PETRINO THE WAY THAT PETRINO
LEFT AND IT REALLY IT REALLY
WAS A LOW POINT FOR THAT
FRANCHISE AFTER THE MIKE VICK
FIASCO PETRINO ONE-AND-DONE
WALKS AWAY WITH GAMES LEFT
AND THEN THE FALCONS NEXT
YEAR. THEY TURNED IT AROUND.
THEY WENT TO THE PLAYOFFS
WITH MATT RYAN AS A ROOKIE
QUARTERBACK BY THE WAY SAINTS.
WASHINGTON OCTOBER 13 2002
SAID 43 SAINTS 27, WASHINGTON,
SO TAKE THAT COACH SPEAR AND
THEN BERTA ME BEAT HIM AGAIN
THE NEXT YEAR. SO SPURRIER
WAS OWEN TWOHIG.
THE SAINTS ARE E-VERSION FROM
HE'S GOT TO BE NICK SABAN.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE THE
ALABAMA COACH TWO YEARS IN
MIAMI. HE WAS MISERABLE IN
THE FACT THAT HE'S BEEN SUCH
A GREAT COLLEGE COACH MAKES
HIS STINT WITH THE NFL. SO
MORE GLARING FOR THE FIASCO
THAT IT WAS RELATIVE TO WHAT
HE'S ACCOMPLISHED IN COLLEGE.
SO WITHOUT QUESTION NICK
SABAN GREATEST COLLEGE COACH
OF ALL TIME, NOT THE GREATEST
PROFESSIONAL COACH OF ALL
TIME. NOT THE GREATEST
TIME NOT BY A LONG SHOT.
PROFESSIONAL COACH OF ALL
AND THERE'S ANOTHER ONE MIKE
TIME NOT BY A LONG SHOT.
WHO WAS A GREAT COLLEGE COACH
AND THERE'S ANOTHER ONE MIKE
AND WAS A COLOSSAL FAILURE IN
WHO WAS A GREAT COLLEGE COACH
THE NFL. THAT'S LOU HOLTZ. HE
AND WAS A COLOSSAL FAILURE IN
WAS HORRIBLE. HE HAD CHOICES
THE NFL. THAT'S LOU HOLTZ. HE
FROM THREE TEAMS AND HE
WAS HORRIBLE. HE HAD CHOICES
SELECT THE JETS BECAUSE HE
FROM THREE TEAMS AND HE
SAID THERE AREN'T MANY TEAMS
SELECT THE JETS BECAUSE HE
IN THE NFL BETTER THAN JETS.
SAID THERE AREN'T MANY TEAMS
GUESS WHAT THE 1976 JETS WENT
IN THE NFL BETTER THAN JETS.
3 AND 10. THEY AVERAGED 12
GUESS WHAT THE 1976 JETS WENT
POINTS A GAME 12 POINTS. YES
3 AND 10. THEY AVERAGED 12
12. THEY ALLOWED 27.2 HE
POINTS A GAME 12 POINTS. YES
DECIDES HE'S GOING TO RUN THE
12. THEY ALLOWED 27.2 HE
VEER OFFENSE WITH JOE NAMATH
DECIDES HE'S GOING TO RUN THE
AND BAD KNEES BAD DECISION
VEER OFFENSE WITH JOE NAMATH
AND OH BY THE WAY THE BEST
AND BAD KNEES BAD DECISION
STORY ABOUT THAT TEAM DURING
AND OH BY THE WAY THE BEST
THE PRESEASON AFTER THEY WANT
STORY ABOUT THAT TEAM DURING
A GAME. HE HANDS EACH PLAYER
THE PRESEASON AFTER THEY WANT
WORDS TO A JETS FIGHT SONG
A GAME. HE HANDS EACH PLAYER
WHO KNEW THEY HAD A FIGHT
WORDS TO A JETS FIGHT SONG
SONG AND SAID, WE'RE GOING TO
WHO KNEW THEY HAD A FIGHT
LEARN TO SING THIS AFTER
SONG AND SAID, WE'RE GOING TO
THOUGHT THAT MAYBE THE
LEARN TO SING THIS AFTER
PLAYERS LOST ON PURPOSE SO
THOUGHT THAT MAYBE THE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO SING THE
PLAYERS LOST ON PURPOSE SO
FIGHT SONG. OH GOD. I DIDN'T
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO SING THE
KNOW ABOUT THAT ONE. BUT I
FIGHT SONG. OH GOD. I DIDN'T
DEFINITELY REMEMBER LOU HOLTZ
KNOW ABOUT THAT ONE. BUT I
AS THE COACH OF THE JETS
DEFINITELY REMEMBER LOU HOLTZ
UNFORTUNATE. I REMEMBER HIM
AS THE COACH OF THE JETS
AS THE COACH OF NOTRE DAME
UNFORTUNATE. I REMEMBER HIM
WHEN THEY BEAT WEST VIRGINIA
AS THE COACH OF NOTRE DAME
FOR THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP
WHEN THEY BEAT WEST VIRGINIA
IN 1988. NEXT ONE FOR ME. I'M
FOR THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP
TORN HERE.
IN 1988. NEXT ONE FOR ME. I'M
I'M TORN BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
TORN HERE.
ALL THINGS CONSIDERED AND IN
I'M TORN BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
LIGHT OF THE HYPE THAT HE
ALL THINGS CONSIDERED AND IN
ENTERED THE NFL WITH AND HOW
LIGHT OF THE HYPE THAT HE
HE WAS GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE
ENTERED THE NFL WITH AND HOW
THE GAME. I GOT TO GO CHIP
HE WAS GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE
KELLY. I GOTTA GO CHIP KELLY.
THE GAME. I GOT TO GO CHIP
I KNOW YOU WENT TO THE
KELLY. I GOTTA GO CHIP KELLY.
PLAYOFFS HIS FIRST YEAR WITH
I KNOW YOU WENT TO THE
THE EAGLES, BUT IT WAS ALL
PLAYOFFS HIS FIRST YEAR WITH
DOWNHILL FROM THERE FIRED
THE EAGLES, BUT IT WAS ALL
IN DONE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
DOWNHILL FROM THERE FIRED
THEN DONE AND DONE FOREVER IN
IN DONE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE NFL WITH ALL THAT AND I
THEN DONE AND DONE FOREVER IN
REMEMBER PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
THE NFL WITH ALL THAT AND I
WERE ACTING LIKE, THIS IS
REMEMBER PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
VINCE LOMBARDI REINCARNATED
WERE ACTING LIKE, THIS IS
COMING TO THE NFL AND I
VINCE LOMBARDI REINCARNATED
EVER THINK WHAT WAIT BECAUSE
COMING TO THE NFL AND I
HAVE INDIVIDUALIZED SMOOTHIES.
EVER THINK WHAT WAIT BECAUSE
WHAT DO YOU WHAT WHAT IS IT
HAVE INDIVIDUALIZED SMOOTHIES.
THAT CHIP KELLY HAS
WHAT DO YOU WHAT WHAT IS IT
DISCOVERED OUT IN OREGON THAT
THAT CHIP KELLY HAS
SOMEHOW IS GOING TO
DISCOVERED OUT IN OREGON THAT
REVOLUTIONIZE PROFESSIONAL
SOMEHOW IS GOING TO
FOOTBALL AND I'M KIND OF GLAD
REVOLUTIONIZE PROFESSIONAL
THAT IT DIDN'T BECAUSE I WAS
FOOTBALL AND I'M KIND OF GLAD
SICK OF HEARING ABOUT IT. AND
THAT IT DIDN'T BECAUSE I WAS
HE DID AND I'M GOING TO STICK
SICK OF HEARING ABOUT IT. AND
WITH THAT SAME STATE MIKE AND
HE DID AND I'M GOING TO STICK
I'M GOING TO GO IT WAS A
WITH THAT SAME STATE MIKE AND
TOUGH CALL, BUT I'M GONNA GO
I'M GOING TO GO IT WAS A
WITH MIKE RILEY FROM OREGON
TOUGH CALL, BUT I'M GONNA GO
STATE. HE WAS EIGHT AND
WITH MIKE RILEY FROM OREGON
FOURTEEN AND TWO SEASONS AT
STATE. HE WAS EIGHT AND
OREGON STATE COMES OUT
FOURTEEN AND TWO SEASONS AT
CHARGERS HARD AND WHY NO IDEA
OREGON STATE COMES OUT
RYAN LEAF SECOND SEASON, THEY
CHARGERS HARD AND WHY NO IDEA
EIGHT AND EIGHT 99 1 IN 15 AND
RYAN LEAF SECOND SEASON, THEY
MM SURPRISED EVEN GET FIRED
EIGHT AND EIGHT 99 1 IN 15 AND
AFTER THAT SEASON AND THEN 5
MM SURPRISED EVEN GET FIRED
AND 11 2001 AND HE WAS
AFTER THAT SEASON AND THEN 5
HISTORY WENT BACK TO THE
AND 11 2001 AND HE WAS
COLLEGE RANKS AND HAD A GOOD
HISTORY WENT BACK TO THE
CAREER AGAIN AT OREGON STATE
COLLEGE RANKS AND HAD A GOOD
IT FOR ME AND AND YOU KNOW,
CAREER AGAIN AT OREGON STATE
THERE ALWAYS IS A FINE LINE
IT FOR ME AND AND YOU KNOW,
BETWEEN THINKING OUTSIDE THE
THERE ALWAYS IS A FINE LINE
BOX AND AND JUST YOU KNOW
BETWEEN THINKING OUTSIDE THE
NUTTY AND IT WAS GREG SCHIANO
BOX AND AND JUST YOU KNOW
WHEN HE WAS PLUCKED BY THE
NUTTY AND IT WAS GREG SCHIANO
TIME WHEN NO ONE WAS TALKING
WHEN HE WAS PLUCKED BY THE
ABOUT GREG. SCHIANO IS BEING
TIME WHEN NO ONE WAS TALKING
AN NFL COACH AND AND AGAIN,
ABOUT GREG. SCHIANO IS BEING
IT'S ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE AND
AN NFL COACH AND AND AGAIN,
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T
IT'S ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE AND
KNOW WHERE WE WIRED TO BE
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T
GLASS HALF FULL OR IF WE'RE
KNOW WHERE WE WIRED TO BE
GOING TO BE WRONG. WOULD WE
GLASS HALF FULL OR IF WE'RE
RATHER BE WRONG BY PRAISING
GOING TO BE WRONG. WOULD WE
SOMEONE THEN BY SAYING THIS
RATHER BE WRONG BY PRAISING
ISN'T GOING TO WORK?
SOMEONE THEN BY SAYING THIS
I REMEMBER THERE WAS ALL THIS
ISN'T GOING TO WORK?
OVER-THE-TOP PRAISE FOR WHAT
I REMEMBER THERE WAS ALL THIS
SHAUNA WAS GOING TO DO AND
OVER-THE-TOP PRAISE FOR WHAT
EVERYTHING IN MAN. WE'LL SEE
SHAUNA WAS GOING TO DO AND
DIDN'T TAKE TO HIM AND IT ALL
EVERYTHING IN MAN. WE'LL SEE
WAS THAT FOR GREG SCHIANO AS
DIDN'T TAKE TO HIM AND IT ALL
AN NFL HEAD COACH DIDN'T LAST
WAS THAT FOR GREG SCHIANO AS
LONG AND HE'S NOT COMING BACK